hi this video will quickly review the
several type of reversible inhibition
how the kinetic data look like under
under these conditions so let's begin
first we'll talk about the competitive
inhibition in competitive inhibition the
substrate and the inhibitor compete for
the enzymes active site and the
substrate and the inhibitor has a
striking similarity such that both can
fit into the active side of the enzyme
and thereby they can compete for the
enzymes active site inhibitor binds to
the enzyme instead of substrate creating
an enzyme inhibitor complex and that's
why the reaction does not proceed
further and don't we do a product
formation second type of innovation is
uncompetitive inhibition where the
inhibitor binds to the enzyme substrate
complex and forms an enzyme substrate
inhibitor and as a result of that the
substrate is not converted into the
product a third type is a mixed
inhibition where the inhibitor is able
to bind to the enzyme and also it is
able to bind to the enzyme substrate
complex so it is kind of a hybrid type
of competitive and uncompetitive
inhibition that's why it is known as
mixed inhibition now let's look at how
the Michaelis Menten equation looks like
under all these circumstances
so first talk about the competitive
inhibition where the Michaelis Menten
equation is given by this where p0 is P
max into substrate concentration divided
by alpha km into s so already you can
understand that instead of km now this
came apparent is alpha came so km has
kind of increased for any positive value
of alpha
km would be increased right and when
there is no inhibition km would be 1 so
here is how the curve would look like
the curve would slightly shift right
wards shifting the km values as you can
see here but the v-max is unchanged from
this graph we can understand
let's talk about the uncompetitive
inhibition in this situation the
equation looks like somewhat this v-0
equal to v-max into substrate
concentration km plus alpha - - this now
this alpha - is another rate constant
here the curve looks like this and from
the curve what you can tell both game
and v-max has decreased so you can
understand km and v-max has decreased in
case of uncompetitive inhibition we can
really appreciate while v-max has
decreased and why we Max has decreased
to a degree of v-max by alpha - but what
why km is decreased decreasing K means
increasing affinity of the enzyme
towards the substrate but how in this
can kind of innovation that happens in
order to understand that watch my video
on uncompetitive inhibition where I have
derived this uncompetitive inhibition
equation and by there I have explained
how the Kame decrease is fitting into
this whole derivation and link is given
at the end of this video let's talk
about mixed innovation here there are
two factors you can see the instead of
km there is alpha came and instead of
only substrate concentration there is
alpha - substrate concentration because
there are two components right one for
competitive and one for uncompetitive
and here is how the curve should look
like now in this particular situation
the v-max decreased definitely but most
of the cases it has been seen there
could be increase in cave or there could
be a decrease in game now as this is a
hybrid of uncompetitive and competitive
both kind of change in km is possible
right but in this particular graph what
we have shown is cam has increased and
this particular situation the mixed
inhibition is resembling more towards
the competitive innovation but here note
the difference in comparative innovation
the v-max does not decrease
whereas
kind of mixed innovation that pmags
decrease now let's try to look at the
lineweaver-burk plot in order to
understand the kinetic data in a better
manner so here is how for competitive
inhibition
lineweaver-burk plot looks like so you
can see the equation here given in
orange here we can see the slope is
alpha km by V Max whereas without any
kind of inhibition the slope is came by
Fe max clearly you can see the slope has
increased because it is multiplied by a
factor alpha for any positive values of
alpha which is greater than 1 the slope
would be bigger than the without in
heater right and that's why we can
understand this red line is much more
steeper than this blue line that makes a
sense right but you can see both the
lines intercept the y-axis at the same
point that means our v-max is unchanged
but you can see the red one has shifted
right words in the negative x-axis so 1
by alpha game has been changed now since
alpha K since game has increased 1 by
alpha km has decreased in this negative
x-axis now for uncompetitive inhibition
the Michaelis Menten equation in a
lineweaver-burk format looks like
parallel lines where the red line is
much more steeper remember here both
v-max and km has decreased right so
definitely if v-max and km has decreased
then 1 by V Max and 1 by gain would be
increased right and that's why you can
see the line is much more steeper and
the line intercept the negative x-axis
where left side then we come to mixed
inhibition in the mixed inhibition we
can see the v-max has decreased that
means there is a change in slope here as
well the alpha km by V Max is the new
slope so the line become more steep
and the line are these lines are meeting
at a point which is away from the y-axis
now one important thing in this
situation is depending upon the value of
alpha dash or alpha there could be
changing the game depending upon the
values of alpha and alpha dash the game
could increase or decrease the apparent
km could increase and decrease so in
case of mixed innovation in short v-max
has decreased for sure but the came the
apparent came could also increase or
decrease so that was pretty much the
overview of the kinetic data and how the
equations and the graphs look like under
all these kind of reversible equal
inhibitions but if you need detailed
information about all these inhibition
types do watch my enzyme Awaji playlist
where I have explained all of these
inhibition types and their derivation
step by step so I hope you enjoyed this
short video and it was informative if
you liked this video give a big thumbs
up don't forget to lock like share and
subscribe thank you